hay un dogma generalizado entre algunos
filósofos y académicos de que la
búsqueda de una teoría de la mente o la
comprensión de nuestra conciencia está
fuera de la ciencia
yo creo que esto sería muy decepcionante
porque posiblemente cada pregunta que
vale la pena sobre nuestra vida sobre
nuestra existencia tenga una respuesta
en la comprensión de la mecánica de la
mente después de todo es el origen de
nuestra experiencia
mi búsqueda personal por una teoría de
la mente inicia del lado de la
inteligencia artificial y la robótica
hace un par de años dedicaba la mayor
parte de mi tiempo construyendo y
programando robots humanoides que fueran
capaces de jugar fútbol por sí solos
ahora hay una gran cantidad de
desinformación en torno a la
inteligencia artificial y la robótica y
yo creo que parte de esta confusión se
da porque estamos confundiendo conceptos
pensamos que robótica es lo mismo que
inteligencia artificial y pensamos que
es lo mismo que inteligencia artificial
y son conceptos completamente diferentes
conciencia artificial
voy a entrar más a detalle en este tema
pero vamos a entender primero lo que es
inteligencia
la inteligencia es primero la capacidad
de un ente de tomar decisiones que
maximicen la probabilidad de lograr un
objetivo ahora para tomar decisiones
correctas necesita tener la capacidad de
crearse un modelo de la realidad a
partir de la percepción de su entorno a
estas capacidades les llamamos
capacidades cognitivas ver escuchar
sintetizar información y por supuesto
aprender
cuando nosotros pensamos en la
inteligencia artificial en lo primero
que pensamos es en nuestros robots sin
embargo estos robots no son la
inteligencia artificial eso nos hacen
pensar porque al final de cuentas pues
crean un modelo de la realidad toman
decisiones hacia un objetivo que es
anotar gol pero sin embargo carecen de
la capacidad de aprendizaje
es decir nosotros los desarrolladores
fuimos los que le enseñamos cada una de
las secuencias de decisiones le
enseñamos a entender su entorno a seguir
por la pelota y cuando cometió un error
nosotros éramos los que aprendíamos en
el robot y luego lo programamos en
nuestro robot
eso quiere decir que la inteligencia no
está en el robot sino en sus
desarrolladores o bueno al menos eso nos
gustaba decirlo
esto empieza a cambiar en el año 2012
mientras en londres se jugaban las
competencias a las olimpiadas humanas en
bristol se jugaban las olimpiadas
robóticas este año convertimos a mexico
en campeón del mundo y una etapa
increíble de mi vida finalizada para dar
paso a la siguiente ese mismo año
confunde una empresa dedicada a explotar
comercialmente estas tecnologías y esto
me permitió a su vez fondear mi propia
investigación en un área de las ciencias
computacionales llamada aprendizaje
automático
y la razón es que este año máquinas que
se programan por sí solas empiezan a
superar por mucho las expectativas me
refiero por supuesto a las redes
neuronales artificiales
las redes neuronales en realidad la
investigación y los procesos llevan más
de 60 años
y todos los conocimientos en el mundo
académico sin embargo no teníamos ni la
cantidad de datos ni la capacidad de
cómputo suficiente para hacer digamos
algo impresionante todo esto empieza a
cambiar en el año 2012
las redes neuronales funcionan a partir
de indicándole a una serie de nodos un
objetivo al que queremos llegar y
entonces a partir de ciclos de cambio y
selección se van optimizando los pesos
de estos nodos hacia a resolver el
problema que nosotros le indicamos
a través de flujos de información se
podría decir hoy sabemos que las redes
neuronales son tienen una capacidad de
cómputo universal es decir que pueden
recrear cualquier operación
computacional sólo están en teoría
limitado por cuatro variables
estas son por supuesto la capacidad
computacional
contar con una cantidad suficiente de
datos
tener también la capacidad de modelar el
problema que queremos resolver
matemáticamente y por supuesto ayudaría
a conocer desde un inicio o elegir la
arquitectura de conexión entre estas
neuronas más adecuadas
hace 20 años se desarrolló un
y una arquitectura de redes neuronales
basada en el córtex visual humano y
nosotros tomamos esta investigación para
enseñarle a la máquina a reconocer
imágenes y empezó a tener resultados muy
parecidos a los que tenemos nosotros
incluso algunos errores por ejemplo
cuántos de ustedes pensaron que la
persona en las gradas es la pelota
bueno pues increíblemente cuando le
enseñamos esta imagen a la máquina
también pensó que era la pelota y esto
lo hizo porque empezó a analizar la
imagen en base al contexto una vez que
le quitamos el contexto en este caso del
fútbol
pues ya lo identificó como un humano
si nosotros le enseñamos a una máquina a
ver como nosotros va a empezar a cometer
los mismos errores que nosotros
este y otro otra serie de modelos
bioinspirados nos han ayudado voy a
enseñarle a las máquinas no solo a
reconocer objetos oa ver sino también a
leer escribir hablar y escuchar e
incluso a tomar decisiones sintetizar la
información
todos estos estas nuevas capacidades hoy
las hemos usado para crear soluciones
muy específicas para la industria esto
nos han ayudado a desarrollar la empresa
entonces ahora sí podemos decir que
estamos de alguna manera o que hemos
creado un tipo de inteligencia
artificial pequeña o una nave artificial
intelligence
pero bueno ahora vamos a pasar
a la parte de la mente que es realmente
complicada la conciencia no entendemos
del todo que es la conciencia y sin
embargo su existencia al menos de la
propia es lo único que podemos estar
seguros y también debemos de estar
convencidos de dos cosas la primera es
que no hay nada más importante que la
experiencia de seres conscientes que
habitan en este universo y la segunda es
que probablemente la conciencia sea el
sistema más complejo del universo
al inicio les platica que había una
confusión generalizada igual de entre
inteligencia y conciencia y yo creo que
esta confusión se da porque nosotros
tenemos la ilusión de que es la
conciencia la que toma las decisiones y
entonces si el ser inteligente es tomar
decisiones inteligentes pues no podemos
separar este concepto de inteligencia y
conciencia sin embargo una serie de
estudios han demostrado desde hace mucho
tiempo que no es la conciencia la que
toma las decisiones sino éstas se
procesan en otras regiones del cerebro y
luego la conciencia se entera de hecho
un experimento del científico benjamin
live incluso pudo detectar el momento en
el que una decisión es tomada en alguna
región del cerebro y el tiempo que pasa
entre que la conciencia se entera
le da sentido a esta decisión y la toma
como propia
en los últimos avances incluso han
podido predecir una decisión 10 segundos
antes de que la conciencia se entere
acaso queda alguna duda de que el libre
albedrío es una ilusión
pero bueno entonces si la conciencia no
es la que toma las decisiones entonces
qué es la conciencia
la conciencia es el espectador de la
mente es el sensor que codifica la
experiencia de ver escuchar y sentir
para entonces generar el conocimiento de
que se siente ser uno mismo
qué ambicioso pensar que en algún
momento vamos a poder recrear o entender
algo tan subjetivo como la conciencia
sin embargo yo creo que estamos más
cerca de lograrlo de lo que pensamos
voy a entrar a una parte un poco más
complicada me gustaría presentarles tres
líneas de investigación sobre la
conciencia
la primera es la correlación neurológica
ésta intenta identificar las zonas en el
cerebro que se activan cuando nosotros
estamos teniendo un tipo de experiencia
subjetiva o alguna experiencia emocional
del lado consciente los experimentos que
les mostré hace rato se realizan
precisamente en esta área de
investigación si nosotros les
preguntamos a esos neurocientíficos
cuánto tiempo falta para poder entender
la conciencia o replicarla te van a
decir que al menos estamos a 100 años de
distancia
luego sigue la teoría de la información
integrada del científico giulio tononi
con un y ha sido capaz de crear los
axiomas necesarios en la arquitectura y
los flujos de información para que la
conciencia pueda surgir a través de una
variable llamada fi
esta es la teoría matemática
experimental líder de la conciencia y ha
sido consistente en medir por ejemplo
cuando una persona está despierta o bajo
anestesia a partir de este valor de la
conciencia
tonini se imagina o él piensa que
simplemente con tener un valor elevado
de fi es suficiente para que la
conciencia emergerá sin embargo yo
considero junto con algunos críticos que
aunque un valor necesario de fíes
necesaria para que la conciencia surja
no es la única condición y aquí es donde
entra la tercera línea de investigación
la psicología evolutiva trata de
explicar la conciencia a partir de esas
causas es decir de preguntarse cuál es
la razón de existir de la conciencia
porque tuvo que surgir en la selección
natural
y el científico nicolás juanfri parece
haberle dado justo en el blanco hace
casi más de 30 años
la hipótesis de juanfran nos dice que
nosotros al tener la capacidad de saber
lo que se siente ser uno mismo
desarrollamos también la capacidad de
saber qué se siente ser alguien más esto
a su vez desarrolla en nosotros un tipo
de psicólogo interno que tiene la
capacidad de leer la mente de los demás
esto por supuesto nos permite cooperar
mejor entre nosotros pero también
predecir el comportamiento de alguna
persona e incluso manipularla
estos son enormes ventajas competitivas
y surgirían a partir de la selección
natural
carl sagan dijo en su serie de kosmos
hace muchos años que nosotros éramos la
manera en la que el universo se conoce a
sí mismo si la hipótesis de juanfri es
correcta quiere decir que la conciencia
es la manera en la que la mente se
conoce a sí misma
hace poco menos de dos años llegué a la
conclusión de que la hipótesis de compro
y podría ser la última parte en este
rompecabezas para generar una conciencia
artificial al inicio de la práctica les
comenté que había cuatro variables que
necesitábamos para recrear una red
neuronal o para hacerla funcionar
la hipótesis de humphrey es la guía de
optimización que nos hacía falta para
recrear esta
esta conciencia artificial porque
precisamente las redes neuronales
recurrentes que tienen un valor elevado
de fi
es la arquitectura que nos sirve para
predecir un valor en el futuro a partir
de información del pasado esto hace que
dos teorías de la conciencia
completamente diferentes apunten hacia
un mismo modelo neuronal
ahora de dónde vamos a sacar los datos
si nosotros alimentamos a una red
neuronal recurrente con información
sensorial de una persona por años y
luego le pedimos que prediga el
comportamiento de esa persona o las
decisiones a partir de esta información
histórica o de este aprendizaje de
información histórica la red neuronal va
a tener que crear un modelo de la
conciencia un modelo de la mente de esta
persona para poder hacer esta predicción
esto quiere decir que habremos generado
una auténtica conciencia artificial
ahora cuánta capacidad de cómputo
necesitamos para eso algunos estudios
sugieren que simular el cerebro humano
requeriría alrededor de 100.000
teraflops de información o sin medel
teraflops de poder de cómputo más bien
esta es justo
la capacidad de cómputo alcanzada en
2016 por la computadora zhongwei tyson
light
pero bueno aún si nos hiciera falta un
poco más de poder computacional me
gustaría poner la semana gráfica para
ponerlos mejor en contexto
en 1997 si nosotros tomábamos el poder
de cómputo de las 500 computadoras más
poderosas del mundo nos daba día extra
flores de potencia hoy en día nosotros
podemos comprar ese poder de cómputo en
una tarjeta de videojuegos
no estoy seguro de que mi hipótesis sea
correcta y desafortunadamente todavía no
tenemos las herramientas para
comprobarlo sin embargo en esta búsqueda
por la creación de una mente artificial
ha crecido en mi la intuición de que
estamos más cerca de llegar a una
conciencia artificial puede llegar a
recrear las circunstancias para que una
conciencia artificial surja de lo que
estamos de comprender e incluso de
entender sus
y sus consecuencias y no sólo me refiero
a las éticas sino también bueno
tanto las existenciales como las éticas
estoy completamente de acuerdo con el
científico y neurocirujano sam harris de
que nosotros debemos de crear una
ciencia que sea capaz de decirnos los
valores humanos y la moral a partir de
comprender la experiencia de seres
conscientes
hoy quiero también invitarlos a que se
deshagan o cuestionen ese dogma de que
una conciencia artificial no es posible
de que una mente artificial no es
posible e incluso una mente que podría
contar con capacidades de manipulación
que nosotros no podríamos ni comprender
porque es el momento de que empecemos a
pensar
en un nuevo modelo económico político y
moral que sea compatible con estos
desarrollos tecnológicos porque pueden
llegar antes de lo que pensamos y puede
ser demasiado tarde muchas gracias
[Aplausos]